there's actually all the adults there
but let me tell you police did find
these eleven children ages 1 to 15 last
week hungry and malnourished living in
this compound in rural New Mexico they
also found an ar-15 530 round loaded
magazines and four loaded pistols now
according to court records from just a
few hours ago these five defendants that
you see here two men and three women
trained at least one of the children and
how to use a gun quoting from those
records a foster parent of one of the
eleven children stated the defendant had
trained the child in the use of an
assault rifle and preparation for a
future school shooting additional
charges filed specifically against the
women for transmitting kids beyond state
lines for the purpose of receiving
advanced weapons training to commit
future acts of violence now police
executed the search warrant last week
after receiving the texts saying we are
starving need food and water a SWAT team
after seeing a firing range on the
property moved in unannounced and
arrested the five suspects now they were
looking for a boy three year old Abdul
Wahab he was kidnapped last year by his
father Suraj who believed the boy was
possessed by the devil and plan to
perform an exorcism in fact the boy
could not walk because of epilepsy
now Suraj's father is a controversial
Islamic cleric it was an unindicted
co-conspirator in the 93 World Trade
Center bombing according to the New Year
Post The Daily News and Senator Chuck
Schumer the cleric also called the CIA
and the FBI terrorists and defended the
man who was ultimately convicted in the
Trade Center bombing so court records
say some of these kids who are now in
state custody Dana told police that in
the last few days they saw that three
year old boy Abdul that use in the
compound he has now assumed to be dead
police retrieved what they believe to be
his bones but that has yet to be
confirmed by the coroner right now all
five suspects are in court back to you
Wow thank you William